[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
whatsa Prof what's up
Prof you know the same rubbish is what's
up ever since this world
began it hasn't changed no nothing's
changed the same nonsense the same
queries the same
arguments the same nonsense the same
arguments it's thousands of years old
already Solomon was absolutely right
nothing new Under the Sun no we're going
to talk about a
refreshing subject today you really
think so very controversial one nothing
is ever refreshing when it comes to this
kind of thing no let's open with a word
of Prayer
our heavenly father thank you again for
bringing us together Lord this is a very
controversial subject today and we ask
that you bless us and Enlighten our
minds that we can uplift you through
speaking about these things in Jesus
name amen
yes Martin
propensities towards
disease runs in
families definitely yes my father had
this therefore his offspring has this
there's a history of heart disease in
the family there's a history of cancer
in the family there's that's one of the
first questions you are asked did your
father have it did your mother have it
did they this have it did they have it
right
mhm but did you know that diets also run
in families correct how you ate is like
the Next Generation ate and when you
married your wife and you said but my
mother never cooked like this you're in
big trouble so no matter what you do
you're going to get into trouble because
don't touch my
plate right I think it's a the worst
arguments come from over a plate over a
plate of food yes and my mother made
this thing in this in this way that's it
for one week total silence if you
and probably not anything on your
plate so Martin and the other thing is
good food good health is it just good
food or there other factors that have to
be taken into account other factors but
if you talk about health it's also not
just physical but mental health as well
so there are so many parameters that we
have to look at and uh it
becomes it becomes a
now some people are very good at one of
the
aspects
now if you exercise for example
everybody knows that that is good for
you everybody needs regular
exercise that is why people even with
poor
nutrition can have
longevity yes if they are active let's
say they're working on a farm and
they're busy and they're doing that but
if they have a sedative
lifestyle then life becomes problematic
so some people become almost fanatical
in terms of Fitness but there are other
things which uh they will then leave by
the wayside right some people want to
build muscle MH and they will violate
their health in order to gain the muscle
and they think that they are strong and
therefore
uh this is just
fine so it's not just a question of good
food but you know I can survive with bad
food for a
while uh I cannot survive without
air for more than a couple of minutes
correct then I'm dead right so I need
good air mhm I need good food I need
regular exercise yes I need need water
water I need to cleanse out my
system and I always used to say you know
you don't wash your socks in orange
juice yeah although orange juice is very
good yes but your system has to extract
the water and use that and get the
nutrients out of that so your system
sometimes wants a good flush yes a good
clean up and unfortunately it also has
to be good water it has to be good water
now we could have a whole discussion
just on
water because water is not water is not
water is not water there are different
kinds of water now some people
believe you know if you purify the
water then that's fine now you're
drinking nice clean water but water has
a crystalline
structure because the various Bonds in
the water molecule ensure a particular
arrangement of the molecules and in
actual fact a drop of water is almost
like one molecule yeah because they're
all
interconnected with a positive to the
negative charges the oxygen against the
hydrogen and it gives a particular
structure and that also affects the the
surface tension of the
water now as soon as you add mineral
into the mix it changes the
structure if you add impurities into the
mix it changes the
structure so one of the the water
sources that have excellent qualities is
artesian well
water now how does that work it comes
deep out of the ground right yeah and
it's an amazing system you know I'm I'm
always stunned
when I see how God arranged all of these
things so if you take a
tree a tree can be incredibly tall yeah
but the water gets to the top right now
in this tree there are xylm and
flam
channels and the water moves up and they
consist of
cellulose and cellulose is a kind of
sugar structure M that also has
electropositive and Electro negative
aspects hydrogen bonds and oxygen in the
molecule now when that water is absorbed
by the roots of the
tree then the water moves up the
tree by hydrogen bonding so this channel
that consists of the cellulose these
sugar
molecules the water the oxygen will link
to the hydrogen then to the hydrogen to
the oxygen the hydrogen and the next
molecule of water will be attached to
that one and so they're going up in
Tandem and they can go up incredible
Heights and the tree
transpires up there and gets rid of its
its water right and it takes up all of
this takes it up
so that's how the water moves up now the
same happens in a mountain range mhm you
have all your rocks and then you have
quartz crystals in the rocks and
sometimes there are layers of quartz
crystals and sometimes there are
vertical uh uplifted areas that go deep
deep hundreds of meters down into the
rocks and any Subterranean water that
finds these channels because of the
crystalline structure does the same
thing as in a
tree goes up like
this linking linking linking and any
impurity like a heavy metal or
something cannot go along with it yeah
stays behind so that by the time the
water comes out of this artisian well
it's absolutely pure water that's why
you find these Mountain Springs High up
in the mountain and you're wondering how
did they get there right they come from
deep down at the bottom and that
water has a particular structure and a
particular surface area that your cells
love your cell loves it and it enables
it to take up minerals and to absorb
those minerals in a specific way if you
disrupt that
then the surface tension is different
sometimes you drink water and it feels
like just going straight through yes it
doesn't go into the cells and then that
that that's sometimes purified water
like you say yes so what kind of water
is very important so good water my
advice is good spring water is the best
water to drink that's my opinion from
all the reading that I've done on the
matter if I may ask if you read the
label on the spring water what will be
anything negative on there that you
should look for well they often give the
the quantities of minerals or or
substances in there it shouldn't be high
in sodium etc etc if it says spring
water and it tastes sweetish to The
Taste then it's probably good water yeah
prepared water is not good water well
it's not in the same class as artisian
well water basically what I'm saying
Martin is the way God designed it is
always the best correct and that's a
principle the way God designed it is
always the best if you want to go to a
mountain stream and you're looking there
and you see tadpoles swimming in the
water that's good water you can drink it
if it's sterile there's nothing there
then be concerned correct all right
people are inclined the other way oh
there's a frog in the water I'm not
going to drink this water the frog is in
the water because it's good water
right so the way God designed it that's
a principle now if you come out of the
world nothing is ever like God designed
it it's as man manipulated it yes that
would be the best right
so what is good food how do you achieve
good health you need
exercise you need good food you need
good water mhm you need sunlight yes
sunlight
sunlight resets your program your
computer program sunlight not only
produces vitamin
D by the radiation impact on the skin
but it also re sets your
hypothalamus your master control
endocrine
gland just below the base of the brain
yeah and then uh you have your pineal
gland which lines up and uh with the
amount of light that comes in light and
darkness Etc sets your melatonin levels
which are incredibly important for a
good immune response
exactly so what do you want want to put
it very simply good food good
water exercise regular exercise and also
strength exercise not just one kind of
exercise you need variety yeah when God
created Humanity he gave them a job mhm
right yes which was a job which entailed
many things some of the wants that
you're going to work with are that high
some of them are way up there some of
them are difficult some of them are not
so difficult you have to bend you have
to lift you have to work you have to do
different kinds of
movement a good workout in a garden is
the best workout you can have so working
an hour or two in the garden per day
shouldn't be seen as diversion it should
be seen as part of your
duty that's the very best exercise that
you could get and if you can take a
spade and dig the ground and have all of
those movements and you need some
strength
exercise did you know that you can have
the worst of diets but if you have
strength exercise and all of these that
go along with it it puts calcium into
your bone mhm just that so you cannot
correct some some things just
by using a one-sided approach correct
that's not not one size fits all correct
and then another thing that's important
Martin your mental health
mhm uh everybody knows that without an
anchor you become
depressed and
disorder creates depression yeah so when
when God comes into the equation
disorder disappears yes order comes into
the life a relationship with
God sets the mind at rest because there
is a a help plan yeah and a
communication a friendship bond that
develops so talking to God having a
relationship with God affects your
health defin defitely and a positive
outlook affects your health MH many many
diseases begin in the mind
yes and the other place where diseases
begin is in the gut
yeah and the gut has its own brain MH
and the gut communicates with the mind
and when that communication is Disturbed
disease is a
consequence so you want to keep a
healthy
gut k m how do you keep a healthy gut
good
food now is this good food just for you
or are there other organisms that reside
in your gut definitely
bacteria okay now those bacteria are
they your friend or are they your enemy
if you treat them badly they become your
enemy if they if you treat them right
they're your friend all right so now if
you ate with the knowledge that you have
a dear
friend in your intestine that you have
invited to
lunch and you know that bad food will
kill
him will you purposefully eat bad food
to destroy your good
friend unfortunately so we
do but you're not supposed
you're not supposed to all right so when
you eat eat consciously that you're not
eating for yourself alone
correct the type of bacteria that you
have in your intestine will largely
contribute to your health
status so you need exercise you need
good food you need good water you need
good fresh air you need sunlight you
need to get your rhythms right you have
to have enough sleep yes you want to
have your meltin levels at the correct
level you want to have communication
with God you want to produce happy
hormones you want to have endorphins in
your life and what gives you endorphins
exercise in itself will give you
endorphins did you know that good music
will give you endorphins as well and
that rock and roll music will destroy
them disturbs the whole system actually
disturbs the whole system so Martin this
is a package you cannot take one
item we've titled it good food good
health and say that is the be all and
end all of a healthy
lifestyle but it is probably one of the
more important ones it's where it starts
that's where it
starts once the food comes right and the
gut comes right then often the Mind
comes right correct when the Mind comes
right you can discern spiritual things
and then suddenly this book becomes very
important and your communication with
God can improve did you know that even
the occult world says that if you want
to have a good spiritual experience you
better eat a particular diet yeah you've
mentioned it before we've spoken about
that before all right so let's attack
this from an holistic point of view and
then we also Martin need to talk
about what happens when things go wrong
correct because that's where most of us
are today yes everything's going wrong
at the moment and what perceptions are
there out there in the
world now we had this discussion about
science right mhm and just because you
have a white coat doesn't mean that you
have the right coat
correct sorry but that is poetic but
it's a it's a true statement it is it's
if you are saying that you've got the we
behind you the wi is not always right
like you said and if you have a white
coat it doesn't mean that you know what
is good for your
plate because what comes to your plate
historically is what you are inclined to
use right correct you mentioned earlier
that even if the diet is a little bit
not the best that it is but somebody
works out and every all this it keeps
him going longer I've got an example for
instance if you take Farmers yes most
Farmers well the older generation
Farmers work hard and that's why
whenever you want to mention something
about Food they'll always tell you but
my
grandfather there are many 80 or 89 or
90 years old and
there that's when you're talking about
diet correct but unfortunately you can't
just mention the look at the diet there
you have to look at his lifestyle so
let's look at all of these things and
see whether we can make some sense out
of it now a few years ago there was a
man who decided that he was going to eat
only
one particular kind of food that was
dished up by a
franchise yeah and what the result was
and uh since then there's been a huge
outcry and some of the menus have
probably changed a little bit here and
there but generally speaking is fast
food the answer to Good
Health definitely not but all right and
we spoke about disease and obes obesity
and all of these issues and that
directly affects your immune response
your health status and uh if there's a
Pandemic those at most at risk will be
those that are overweight that have high
blood pressure and that are compromised
in many many areas right so let's just
look at a little video from that ancient
time
and see what
transpired your blood tests are are
excellent okay you're starting with a
cholesterol total cholesterol of 168
Which is less than 200 which really
superb your blood level's fine your iron
level is good as well you have no
evidence of diabetes your fasting blood
sugar is very low the other thing that
we looked at were all your electrolytes
in terms of your salts in your blood
your kidney function your liver function
they were all perfect your triglycerides
which is is your building blocks of fat
basically from what you acquire from
eating fat is 43 which is low which is
good um I think the worst case scenario
is that you increase your triglycerides
and your cholesterol level and if you
have any um heart disease in the family
or any heart under underlying heart
disease you're putting your heart at
risk uh I expect to see an increase in
your
triglycerides uh because that will uh
can be affected you're at 87 now and I
think that will change mhm and I think
that's the only thing that will
change out of everything out of
everything I mean you know there might
be some minor variations but the body is
extremely adaptable and the kidneys will
handle any extra salt that you're taking
in and your liver will be able to
metabolize additional fat the total
cholesterol is 165 before now it's 225 a
liver that's uh that's inflamed in any
way or sick in any way will will will
leak some of its enzymes out into the
blood so this is very non-specific but
it means the LI the liver is sick yeah
and the most likely cause of your liver
sickness is a fatty liver your liver is
now like Pate SG was originally 21 now
it's 13 and this GPC was originally uh
20 was 20 290 more than 10 fold increase
not good not good not good not good so
somebody were doing this to their level
with alcohol they could theoretically
Wipe Out the liver you know wipe out all
the liver cells and and and and there'd
be in liver failure now I've never heard
of anybody doing this to the liver with
with with with with a high fat diet
there's a drug that is used in emergency
rooms called nxone it's used for heroin
overdose and a guy comes in overdose on
heroin comos he's going to die you
inject him with this drug and it blocks
the opiate receptors in the brain heroin
doesn't work he wakes up if I give that
same drug to a real chocolate addict a
person just shoveling it in you find the
most amazing thing they lose much of
their interest in chocolate they take a
bite they set it back down in other
words it's not taste and mouth feel it's
a drug effect of the food within the
brain that keeps us coming back again
and again if you look at the menu at a
fast food restaurant they use all of the
addicting components they'll take a slab
of meat cover it with cheese cheese of
course which is filled with the Chom
morphins uh the opiates that are that
are found in the cheese protein and then
they serve it with us sugary soda which
has the addictive powers of sugar with
plenty of added caffeine now you might
be a 12-year-old kid your brain is no
match for that combination this is
really you know you you saw these
numbers right these numbers are
absolutely outrageous okay for the first
time we seeing uric acid elevated so
you're giving yourself
hyperemia and the danger of hyperthemia
is gout kidney stones the results for
your liver
are obscene beyond anything I would have
I would have thought yeah truly I I mean
you know that movie uh death in Las
Vegas Nicholas Cage I mean that pickled
his liver during the course of a few
weeks in Las Vegas
right I would would never thought that
you could do the same thing with a high
fat diet yeah uh my advice to you as a
physician is that you got to stop you're
pickling a liver yeah you you know
kicking it while it's down now you know
now it's down and you're going to you're
kicking it
further I mean if you're an alcoholic
I'd say you I say you're going to die
you keep drinking you'll die if a pain
starts to radiate to your jaw down your
arm that's life-threatening and
immediately so yeah so I need to hear
about that or you need to call 911 okay
all right I wouldn't suggest you
continue the diet for a year to to check
this out I don't think it's appropriate
or healthy especially with what showed
up with your liver for a year right so I
shouldn't eat this food for a year no I
don't think so you know we see people
who like go on an alcohol binge and
their numbers go up like crazy but to go
on you know a Mac attack and they've got
numbers to show that you're it attacks
your liver too I would never honestly I
would never I wouldn't have even thought
about this but it it makes sense now
that we have the data it definitely
makes
sense so Martin he's been
of eating only these fast foods
destroyed him to the point where they
were saying if you continue you're going
to die 50 days 30 days that's it so it
tells you something about diet now we
have a culture in the
world where we say that animal foods are
the best to place into your body that is
in direct contradiction with a good book
right
correct and we've we've read this many
many times but it's in direct
contradiction with what this book has to
say because it says
there and God said I have given you
every her her bearing seed which is upon
the face of all the Earth and every tree
in which is the fruit of a tree yielding
seed to you it shall be for meat which
means food remember when the King James
says meat it means food not flesh flesh
is meat flesh is what we call meat today
all
right so the original diet was totally
plant-based every
seed that's every legum every nut
everything that you can imagine of
that's of a seed
nature and then every tree with fruit on
it and then after the
fall vegetables were added to the diet
not
meat and the longevity of humanity was
in excess of 900 years yes when meat was
added to the diet within one generation
it fell to half of that and in the Next
Generation to half of that again until
we are eventually eventually where we
are now 70 and if by reason of strength
it should be 80 You Can Count yourself
lucky right mhm the average life
expectancy is much much lower than that
so we cannot look at the extremes and
make conclusions so the bottom line is
the Bible says that every creature was
vegetarian mhm including every other
animal on the planet and what has
transpired since then is a as a
consequence of
sin when Jesus was asked many
times about why did Moses permit this
etc etc etc it's he would say it was not
so in the beginning yeah so it's
important to have a look at what was it
like in the
beginning and that was the
ideal correct now if you apply that
Health principle today then we know that
if you have a vegetarian diet and
particularly if you have a vegan
diet that is a balanced diet now that is
important and it's important
because just to make it clear it's a
plant-based whole food diet correct
plantbased whole food today the word
vegan is not really what it's supposed
to mean because today it has all kinds
of emotional things added to it you know
like animal cruelty acts etc etc and uh
we're talking about a plant-based diet
yes the
healthful now as we all know because
we've discussed it many times I myself
was a
Carnivor and I was not very healthy can
I just ask um didn't you have a a record
somewhere about a burger eating con oh
yes I I won various competitions and
steak eating oh yeah exercises yes I had
a huge capacity for animal
protein and uh I was a very sickly
person if you think about it I was
incredibly fat and that I think was my
Saving Grace because I played a lot of
squash which is a high energy MH uh
activity but whenever I had a game I
would smell like a horse yeah as the
Salita would come out of my
system and uh your whole your whole
demeanor your your skin everything is
totally different M I had huge paws on
my face because my body was constantly
trying to throw out these
toxins now if you have a high animal
protein
diet then the amino acid
mix that you have is not the same as you
would get from a plant-based diet yeah
so if you have a diet of grains and
legumes which are the seed-bearing
plants right mhm any grain mixed
together with a legum in a meal gives
you a perfect protein with every amino
acid that you
require but even when you have that
perfect complete protein from the grain
legum
combination or grain seed combination or
grain nut combination gives you that
perfect uh amino acid
profile if you get the same complete
protein from an animal protein the ratio
of the amino acids is
different now one of the amino acids
that plant-based diet will give you in
high quantities is the amino acid
arginine now ayine is a very specific
amino acid and it's a very interesting
amino acid because it has more than one
amino group we don't have to go into the
chemistry to confuse people but it has
more than one of these nitrogen groups
right yeah
and it is the amino acid that slots into
your Ura cycle mhm and your urea cycle
is what takes ammonia that comes from
the degradation of proteins from the
digestion of
proteins when that ammonia comes off
ammonia is highly highly
toxic I mean you use ammonia to kill
everything off in your house when you
use it as a household cleaner right
correct whatever it comes into contact
with it'll
kill so the same at your in your cells
when ammonia is set free in your cell
you have to detoxify it immediately or
it will destroy your
cells and that's where the Ura cycle
comes in and the the beginning is
adenine and in the end it splits out
those Amino
groups and it produces
Ura now if you're a bird or a reptile
you'll produce uric acid M now we also
produce uric acid it has more Amino
groups than the other things so a person
that has an
overload of uh animal protein in their
body will also produce URI acid mhm and
that can lead to other issues like gout
and all of the other SE secondary
diseases so a plant-based diet is in
itself a detox diet
correct because it helps the body
because it pushes the reaction in the
direction of Ura production helps the
body to keep it at a level so that you
don't have the buildup of toxins in your
blood another amino acid that is high in
animal
protein uh or the amino acids are the
phenolic amino
acids those are amino acids that have
ring
structures and Phil alanin is one of
them for example now these ring
structures are like Benzene mhm and they
can be cogenic in high concentrations
now if you have a diet that consists of
a high high protein diet low
carbohydrate
diet then your body has to change the
protein into a carbohydrate M because
your brain your nervous system requires
pure carbohydrate yes so now your body
has to work three or four times as hard
to get that same nutrient that your
brain needs correct now the the way
people think in the world is to say
carbohydrates will make me fat mhm
therefore I'll stick to a high protein
diet if you have a high protein diet you
are going to force your body to take
some of the protein that you have eaten
and to convert it into
carbohydrates because your brain cannot
be fed by protein corre it has to
receive
carbohydrates now what is the logical
thing Martin mhm when you receive this
high protein diet and you're taking half
of it and changing it to carbohydrates
you are loading your body with the amino
groups yeah you are loading your body
with the phenolic groups
okay and they are toxic to your body so
you're loading your body with toxins all
right your body can get rid of it
through the Ura cycle excrete the other
some of it goes out through the stool
and sometimes the excess is so high that
it actually crystallizes and sits in
your joints and gives you all kinds of
of problems joint
problems why not reduce that problem by
cutting down the protein and adding the
carbohydrate then you wouldn't have that
problem now the carbohydrate that you
are consuming in what form should it be
oh
it should be a whole food what does that
mean it means it must be a food that
contains what the original contained and
that has two kinds of fibers in it yeah
soluble fiber and insoluble
fiber now the soluble fiber is
amazing it's what produces the gums for
example if you cook a fruit it makes
like a goo and we call that Jam right
yeah that's because of the soluble
fiber the insoluble fiber is the ruffage
mhm that like a scraper yes now the
roughage the insoluble fiber gives you
gut
Mobility so as you have the peristalsis
going down your gut it moves along
easily it also absorbs water so it keeps
the moisture content of your gut uh
perfect and you have good mobility of
food through the intestine so generally
speaking if you eat every day you should
actually get rid of the waste every day
as
well if there is a lag and some people
only go every second day some people
only go once a week to the little room
with the flushing
mechanism what goes in should also go
out readily because that's part of your
detoxifying system for that you need
complex carbohydrates yeah the is does
that system work if you only have an
animal protein diet no it can't work it
will it somewhere in your intestines
you're going to start goinging problem
problems you're going to have
compaction and uh a person who has a
high animal protein diet will receive
that intestinal
compaction that will create the need for
tremendous
pressure to get rid of whatever is in
the
intestine I call it the eye bulging
experience okay if you if you go blood
red when you're sitting on your private
Throne as you try to force out whatever
is the obstacle in in there then there's
something terribly wrong it should be
just a gone yeah right that's how it
should be I just want to come back to
the uh fiber that you were talking about
and just reate the importance that it
has to be whole uh
complete carbohydrate because whenever
it's
processed that the whole system is not
going to work like you've just mentioned
whole food doesn't necessarily mean that
you're not allowed to process it okay
but it must have everything that was in
there originally exactly nothing must be
taken out industry has so changed
Humanity's diet because industry
requires mass production yes now in the
old days you used to go to the Miller MH
and the name Miller is still very common
in the world Mr Miller how are you today
right or in German
H why because there was a Miller yeah
and he had a Stone Mill and he used to
put the Grain in and the stones used to
rub it and grind it and it used to come
out and everything that was in the
original was in the final packet
right people like refined food so they
put it through a Sie and they get rid of
the roughage yeah which is a major
problem now I'm not one that says you
have to have a long face when you eat
it's fine if that is an occasional treat
that you are having but if that is your
lifestyle you have a problem if white
bread is a regular component on your
table you are looking for trouble yeah
in any case I don't understand why
people would want to eat it because it
tastes like
cardboard well that's also you get used
to that taste and then you don't you're
not used to the others correct but if
you switch your lifestyle and you tell
your pallet I don't want that I want a
whole grain
food eventually the other one will
become loathsome to yes if your pallet
changes that just on this
bread there are people that are gluten
intolerant
yes but that's also a cause of humanity
interfering in the original design
correct there are many many ideas about
why people become gluten intolerant and
some of them are associated with
intestinal maladies such as uh celiac
disease or Crohn's
disease where the permeability is such
that the gluten creates an autoimmune
response because it's not absorbed in
the correct way we have to talk about
how you absorb proteins you can but
we'll come to that in a moment and there
are many reasons as to why people can
have problems like that
some say it's because of genetically
modifying the food it's very difficult
to trace from cause to
effect there are interesting graphs in
the world where some people have adverse
reactions
to uh
vaccinations and the correlations
between certain kinds of vaccination and
and celiac disease for example are very
very strong M so there are certain
things that have been introduced that
can cause this but even if you go onto a
gluten-free diet then it must still be a
whole food diet correct that's very
important yes and many many of the of
the gluten-free foods that are produced
by the industry are anything but Whole
Foods correct in fact they are so
refined and just because they are
glutenfree doesn't make them healthy
exactly so that's why we also are going
to produce a program at least as to what
is a whole grain glutenfree bread and
diet for example because that's also
very important that's stays with the
same basic principle correct as soon as
theyve been tampered with anything of
the original yes be careful now when you
eat a whole food plant-based diet you're
not as I said in the beginning you're
not just eating for
yourself you are eating for your Flora
inside your intestine
intestines now certain of the
foods in in the plants that we eat we
actually cannot digest correct some of
the
oligosaccharides that is the the complex
carbohydrates we have no problem with
glucose absorbing that we have no
problem with starches we can digest them
the enzyme amalaye will break them down
and make the sugars available we have no
problem with that but some of the alos
saccharides we cannot digest so in a
potato for example you have mainly
starch but you also have some of these
strange
oligosaccharides now some of the gut
bacteria particularly those in the colon
love those yeah yeah they they for the
for the it's their food so in other
words if you if you think in terms of
creation you can say well God pack
certain things in there that you don't
steal the food that they
need right you have a high animal
protein diet with this high acid
load then those bacteria actually start
dying and you get a totally different
Flora so you will start getting
a flora that has to deal with the amino
groups right and they produce ammonia
correct and this ammonia has to be is an
environment in which only certain
bacteria which actually will lead to
carcinogenesis on the long run therefore
a high fat High animal protein diet is
highly correlated with intestinal cancer
yeah so all of these things are very
important now it's always interesting to
me how or it was fascinating to me to to
determine how protein digestion actually
works when you eat a plant or or an
animal product and it contains a
protein all the amino acids are in that
protein MH some proteins are hard to
digest and some are are easier to
digest now in your stomach you have an
enzyme called pepsin mhm and pepsin
takes a protein and chops it up
into chunks yeah yeah so it breaks it up
into polypeptides right little
chunks and the more animal protein there
is the longer it takes to digest M okay
so if you're having a diet that contains
let's
say a plant based food carrot a potato
fruit or
whatever and you put an animal protein
in it as well like meat or casine from
cheese your body will determine how long
that food has to stay in the stomach we
spoke about that before
satiety
yes do I feel full yes now your body
will digest slight a washing machine
doing its thing adding the product that
will break down the proteins and the
foods then it sends through a
sample through the duodenum and there
are receptors in that part of the dium
that tell you how far has the protein
digestion run its
course and if it's not very adequate it
closes up the stomach okay stays in so
you going through a another washing
machine cycle then it send through a
sample and if you've had cheese in your
diet for example it will say stay there
stay there stay there stay there stay
there for hours on end in the mean time
the stuff that is in there in a warm
gooey environment starts fermenting
because they don't get digested in the
stomach correct so here you have this
major problem so when you're eating a
carbohydrate the first digestion starts
in your mouth because you have the
enzyme amas there but when it gets to
the stomach it's an acid environment and
the more animal protein there is in that
stomach the more acid it has to be for
the enzyme to work
optimally so any Animal product that
goes into your stomach increases the
acidity now your immune system loves to
run on a slightly alkaline system yes
alkaline alkaline it doesn't like an
acid
system then as it passes through
eventually with the carbohydrates having
fermented now in other words you no
longer getting carbohydrates they
fermented to fatty acids MH that adds to
your acid load right yeah so a diet that
contains animal protein is a high acid
diet the most acid foods are
cheese then come the meats mhm if you
take a plantbased protein it is slightly
acid forming like most U nuts yeah Etc
slightly acid forming and some are even
alkaline forming which is amazing
because they contain amino acids but
they're so balanced with mineral that
they're actually slightly alkaline for
example almonds are slightly
alkaline uh most grains are only
slightly acid but some grains are
actually alkaline like
melet is an alkaline grain so if you're
suffering with acid load then you want
to include uh grains that are alkaline
forming like Millet and sorghum and
those in to your diet so if you're going
to have a diet that is alkaline forming
and it'll be automatically alkaline
forming if it is a plant-based diet yeah
fruit even the most acid fruits like
lemon alkaline forming yeah and your
body loves it and your bacteria are
jumping for joy so if you have these
healthy bacteria in your
stomach then that already sends a signal
to your brain everything is honky Dory
and this communication between the brain
in your
intestines and your master brain is very
very
important now the protein breaks up into
chunks in your stomach it goes through
the diod denum and another enzyme is
added which is tripon MHM and that'll
break the big chunks into smaller
chunks then it pass there's no free
amino acid at this stage right no then
it passes down your intestine and as it
goes lower and lower the intestinal wall
has particular cells that produce
enzymes and these are called
ectopeptidases and they start cutting
off the amino acids so the free amino
acids only occur very low down in your
intestine and there they are absorbed by
the hepatoportal
vascular system which takes it out and
takes it to your
liver in your liver your liver repacks
the proteins into
dipeptides putting the amino acids at
least linking them together into chains
of two or three or four tripeptides etc
etc and they go into your
bloodstream and then as your cell absorb
these it'll split them off as they need
them and require them as building blocks
enzyme production whatever your cell
needs now the amount of protein you need
is very very small small yeah
75 G per
kilogram yeah so a man of your
stature would need I would guess about
60 grams of protein per day yeah I would
need perhaps 70 75 gr of protein a day
uh the average female between 55 and 65
gr of protein per day and the the
consumption by the general population
especially in my country here South
Africa is three four five six times that
high yes okay
now the
protein you do not store in your
body so whatever excess protein you are
eating over and above that 75 G per
kilogram and if you're a growing child 1
gram per kilogram okay yeah so if a
child weighs 20 kilograms it needs 20 gr
of
protein very little right correct and if
it is a balanced protein then all the
better so because your body doesn't
store this
protein whatever is in excess it has to
[Music]
convert to either
carbohydrates or fats or fats yeah now
those two you can store the fats you
store as
glycogen you can store it in your liver
mhm you can store it in your muscles as
an energy Reserve any in excess of that
is stored in the fat but because you are
detoxifying or trying to detoxify this
massive load of all these phenol groups
and anything else that comes in the
Animal product most of those things are
fat soluble yeah so the fat that you
produce actually also dissolves many of
those
toxins just to separate them from your
bloodstream so the fat that is in your
body if you are on a high animal protein
diet with its concomittant
load of other undesirable
elements you get a lot of hormones
involved in that you get you know it
comes with a package can you imagine the
terror of the animals that are being
slaughtered what the the the cortisol
levels are and the
adrenaline all of that comes with your
meal right correct because it's in the
meat all right now many of the other
chemicals and that are in those products
get dissolved in your fat and they're
stored there then one day you get sick
Martin mhm and you're not feeling well
you might be nauseous you're not eating
right what does your body use then to
keep you going it goes into that fat
exactly especially if you have a fever
you're actually burning a lot of this
fat right and those toxins are
released so your toxic load when you are
burning that fat is heightened yeah that
knocks your immune system
for a
six so how do you keep a good immune
system plant-based diet that's
a whole food plant-based diet that's how
you keep a good immune system so animal
proteins we tested them in the
laboratory we did literally hundreds of
experiments using any animal model that
you can think of where we tested the
immune response and the overall health
status of an animal its cholesterol ol
levels its amino acid profiles it's uh
immune compound it's bone composition
the whole lot when we tested a
plant-based protein diet with an animal
protein based diet the results were
absolutely
staggering on every single level
cholesterol for example you get two
kinds of cholesterol mhm
high density and low
density and the one is associated with
cardiovascular disease the other one not
and the ratio of HDL which is the high
and the low density one which is the LDL
is very important and the plant-based
diet the ratios were always perfect no
matter whether you tested a carnivore or
whether you tested a
herbivore but the ratio was always bad
when it was an animal
protein and also the immune parameters
that we tested so it was absolutely
astounding that you got these consistent
results so your diet very important
let's talk a little bit about what to
eat and how to eat correct so just one
of the graphs that will illustrate what
animal protein will do just in terms of
any cancer that you want to measure in
this case it was lymph gland
cancer then it is per capita animal
protein
consumption per country Japan has a very
low protein consumption relative to
their General diet they're not like the
Westerner that'll have a huge Stak they
will have little slivers or something
but generally a low consumption and then
the Western countries like Canada
Denmark USA the USA is normally always
on the top of the Hit Parade because
they have the worst diet on the planet
yeah generally speaking then you can see
there's a very strong
correlation of this kind of cancer
associated with animal protein
consumption the higher it is the higher
the rate of
cancer if you look at dietary fat and
breast cancer for example and the high
fat diet is always associated with the
high animal protein diet yeah yeah like
cheese for example any dairy product is
very high in fat and animal proteins are
very high in fat and there's these uh
new diets that are specifically high fat
diets to go on to so if you look at the
the Eastern Nations like Japan Thailand
Etc they have a very low breast cancer
rate and again the USA Canada and the
Western countries they have the highest
rate of these kinds of cancer there's no
doubt that there's a very strong
correlation between what goes into your
mouth and what happens in your
body here is milk and breast cancer and
again it's fascinating that the
countries that have the highest rates
are the dairy consuming countries like
Denmark Switzerland Etc
and uh the US of course is always very
high on the head parade and those that
don't really consume milk like Thailand
Japan Etc they consume soy milk correct
they don't have that problem Oh but what
about the estrogen in soy don't irritate
me
Martin that is the most nauseating
question that I received it's based on
total misinformation mhm and it is
surprising to me that no matter how much
science you put out into the world this
stubborn argument is constantly being
thrown at your head now the kind of
estrogen in adverted commas that you
find in
legumes uh particularly in soy for
example is
phytoestrogen and phytoestrogen does not
have the femin izing estrogenic
properties at all there are different
binding sites without going into detail
for
estrogen and everything in in your
endocrine system works on uh not
everything but a lot of it works on a
pushpull
mechanism so you have enhancing and you
have
depressing uh endocrine systems your
prostag glandon work like that on a very
large scale and uh the a whole host of
them so some of them Elevate an issue
some of them depress an issue and that's
how you keep equilibrium and everything
is about equilibrium MH so you want to
have anabolism and you want to have
catabolism you want to activate and you
want to deactivate you don't want to
build when you are digesting then you
want to assimilate once you've
assimilate it then you want to use so
everything has to be organized like this
now this same with uh these
phytoestrogens there are alpab Bend
binding sites and there are beta
building uh binding sites and some of
them will Elevate activities and some of
them will depress activities now the
phytoestrogens bind to The Binding sites
and compete with natural estrogen M and
therefore prevent many of the problems
associated with estrogen for example
cancer yeah breast cancer can be
decreased by this and the it doesn't
compete with the binding sides that have
the feminizing effect correct so they
don't have a feminizing effect I've
always said if you go to the east block
countries they don't walk around with
bras it the men now I'm speaking it is a
fallacy and it's based on misinformation
so the
phytoestrogens that you find in soy are
exactly the same
phytoestrogens that you will find in
flax seed for example and the same
person that says to you you should take
lots of flax seed because it's healthy
for your intestine doesn't know that
he's also in the same breaths telling
you to take phytoestrogens yeah the one
that is in there is Cogen and it's the
same that is in soy
but because soy competes with the dairy
industry ah therefore it has to be
targeted it is absolute
stupidity or ignorance that makes people
speak that way in fact the
phytoestrogens protect you against
diseases and they have nothing to do
with your
masculinity or your virility if you want
to find out which is the most populous
country in the world yeah and which is
one that is well known for its
virility then it is particularly those
Nations that have high consumption of
these very things ex there was a popular
study that was done it was called Game
Changers remember yeah and they tested
the the
testosterone and the virility let's put
it this way of their
masculine subjects and the ones that had
the plant-based diets were they at the
bottom of the scale or were they at the
top of the scale no at the top they were
at the top so these people that have
these huge bulks and use anabolic
steroids to get there they are dwarfing
their masculinity and shouting at those
that are perfectly fine and doing well
because they use phytoestrogens I think
the world is up upside down the devil is
the master of reversal definely that's
why I come back to this that once your
science doesn't correlate with that
Bible correct then it is skew even if it
looks like it's correct correct I give
you every seed bearing plant does that
include flax seeds correct yes does that
include the soybean yes does that
include any other Bean MH so if God says
that is the best diet you take it to the
laboratory you show that it is the best
diet does it convince the people no no
not at all no because they are run by
their pallets correct then they start
looking for scientific evidence and they
actually get scientific evidence that
the alternative to the Bible is actually
correct so you will have you will have
statements uh you know a glass of wine
is good for you all right and uh eat
lots of chocolate
that's good for you and drink lots of
coffee because we found something good
in coffee yeah some test show now that
caffeine is actually there's good in
caffeine exactly but if you look at the
detrimental effects and you see the 40%
reduction in oxygen supplyed to the
brain then it's absolutely ridiculous
that you can even argue like
that so what you eat is very important
and and let's have a look at some of
these things yeah I was thinking maybe
we can just share with the
viewers a normal day of eating in your
life a normal day of eating in my life
no okay my life as well and your life as
well all right because a lot of people
okay so if you've got people now that
decided okay I want to give this a
go where do you go to because we were
like that you you're at a total loss
okay so I want to try this how do I
start where do I start all right all
right what what what is a good diet
we've read it in the Bible M and we've
I've proved it in the labs oh definitely
and many many people have proved it as
well and The China Study stands out as a
monument and many many other Studies
have been done I mean the literature is
replete so a diet that contains a lot of
fruit is an excellent diet right now
fruit contains a lot of water fruit
contains carbohydrates largely contains
very low quantities of protein so this
cannot necessarily constitute all of
your diet no although some people have
gotten by with I eat only fruit correct
you can yeah but uh generally speaking
it doesn't say eat only fruit I give you
every seed bearing plant so a breakfast
of grains and fruits would be an
excellent yes so breakfast we often
start off we start off with a bowl of
mixed fruit all right now what do you
getting in this mixed fruit M you're
getting carbohydrates right you're
getting
water that has is actually cellular
water so it is the exact composition
that your
cell craves yeah all right so that's the
first point it has all the minerals it
is rich in minerals and vitamins it's
rich in vitamin C and depending on what
kind of fruit it is it will have
different components yes and also
important why we start off with fruit is
it digests faster correct now when you
eat fruit grains together their
digestion time is relatively
short which means it passes out of your
stomach and becomes available to you as
energy so if you have a
breakfast of animal
protein that energy is only available to
you about 6 hours later whereas if you
have this a large proportion is
available within a very short time
mm now now what we can see here are
different kinds of fruits now there's a
strawberry for example or a piece of a
strawberry that is the fruit that has
the highest antioxidant level together
with some of the other like the
cranberries and and uh pomegranates and
all of these they have very high and
different levels of
phytochemicals uh the antioxidants now
what is an antioxidant
it is something that mops up free
radicals in your body and free radicals
are carcinogenic so basically what
you're eating here is a food that fires
up your immune system helps your body to
get rid of the free radicals and the
dangerous elements that are produced
constantly because you are metabolizing
yes and helps your body to clean them
out yes can't have better than that but
then you want some energy so you want
some good
bread or whatever grain now three
grains will give you a complete
protein all right Martin I see you put a
picture in here of mixed
seeds now all of these seeds contain
different components like we've said
already if you look at flax seed for
example you have all the omga fats that
you need there in the diet and you know
people always say you need fish yes for
for
your
no because uh when you when you eat fish
you get iosa pentanoic acid mhm whereas
if you eat seeds then you get linolic
and lenol linic acid and that is the
basis of your enzyme Cascade so you can
produce any of
those fatty acids out of those two base
acids that you find in the seeds whereas
if you're getting fish you're getting
iosa pentanoic acid which is something
that can change the clotting parameters
in your blood and you have to be very
careful whether you actually want to do
that so if you start with a seed you can
produce the one that is in fish to the
quantities that your body requires
whereas if you eat in the form of the
fish you have no control about over the
quantity so your body has to constantly
correct whatever the problem is so in
any case this is one of the best things
and I see m in your bowl here you have
pumpkin seeds which again are rich in
phytochemicals that are u a deterrent to
prostate cancer for example in prostate
health so if you grind this all up
either in your mouth or in a machine
yeah we grind the um seeds and we throw
it over our fruit but everybody can do
it in the way that they like that's just
a way that I can get the seeds it's not
as dry or anything and you get quite
used to it to get it into yeah some
people put it into the into their
porridge yeah and here I see you have a
bowl with different grains in them so
run us through this breakfast of your
well the thing is like you said earlier
it has to be three grains yes and they
are
well it doesn't have to be you see
Martin your amino acid pool in your
blood stays there for at least 18 hours
yeah so let's say you only had one grain
for breakfast let's say
oats you might have a shortage of some
things uh if later on in the day you're
eating bread you're adding the second
one yes and that pool stays there so you
don't have to eat it all at the same
time of course if you eat it at the same
time fine but that it helps you with
your staying power yes with your stom
otherwise you're going to be
hungry a little bit e if your body has a
shortage of one element it develops a
craving correct and people that have a
craving for sweet things are actually
satisfying the craving with the wrong
thing yeah the body might be craving
something totally different
but if you have a whole food diet and
here you have three grains which are the
grains that are using here yeah that is
milet and oats and if I remember
correctly that's ground wheat all right
so you have one here of melet which is
an alkaline grain excellent and it is a
complete protein by itself it's one of
the few grains that actually has a
complete protein so it's also important
that you realize that you should buy
dehusked Millet right so you buy from a
health food store or a A supplier that
supplies it for human consumption
because you're not a bird and a bird
Dells it and throws out the little
shells but uh you would have a veritable
chewing experience so let them do that
process for you all right so you put
three grains together you create a three
grain porridge and that should have PL
plenty of sustaining power yeah you and
you and just for to say we prepare it in
different way way sometimes we actually
if because a lot of people don't have
time so you can put this in a slow
cooker for a few hours overnight mhm and
the next morning you got enough of this
meal for 3 days now it's also very
interesting Martin that grains contain
other components which are enzyme
supressant now did God make a mistake
when he put enzyme suppressants in there
no no because the seed has to be kept
dormant and only when it is activated is
that suppressant you eliminated and
cooking also eliminates it so some of
the components like the phytic acids Etc
by putting it in a slow cooker you're
actually getting rid of the enzyme
suppressants the natural enzyme
suppressants yes and sprouting does the
same thing so Sprouts are excellent food
because they have been energized and the
suppressants are all gone that makes it
easier to digest much easier and also
you have the phytochemicals and the the
vitamins being activated inside
it uh here you have a AO and
sauerkraut bread Martin is do you like
that kind of thing yeah this is like
pudding after for breakfast now sakrat
of course is a fermented food right and
as a fermented food if it is in the
Natural State not heated and everything
killed then this is like a probiotic
correct that helps that's that being a
friend to a friend that's helping your
friends sending them some friends to
play with right and keeping the the mix
perfect uh you could also using coconut
milk mil or using soy milk or using
cashew nut milk or a seed milk you could
make your own yogurt yeah so you could
actually just purchase a probiotic
pill and put it in there and keep it at
a a temperature which is almost body
temperature let's say and it'll make its
own yogurt and it will not be Dairy
based that would be similar to fermented
foods and avocado of course is very rich
in
monounsaturated fats and uh it also adds
the Amega fats that you need and it's
very high in folic acid so that is an
energy food and instead of
butter use avocado if you can correct
who says butter must be yellow why can't
it be green exactly and when we started
eating like this you learn all sorts of
spreads that you can make with the all
these uh legumes and you don't have to
have a boring you can make all kinds of
interesting things all right well I must
just add now this is a complete
breakfast the way I eat it at this stage
so it's starting off with fruit three
grain porridge and then ending off with
this so it sounds like a lot of food now
how how do you run on that you run on
that for for a long time can run on that
to about 2 3:00 in the afternoon exactly
now
Martin if you take that slice of bread
and if I look at that slice of bread
over there then I would imagine that
that looks like
a whole
grain uh sourdough bread is that correct
correct
okay we started off with your bread
recipe yes that's also on the videos and
then afterward while we got a nice
sourdough plant now who gave you that
souro PL a very good friend I heard it's
Priceless you can't buy it so no you
can't you can't we must actually do a
little video on good sour dough bread
and uh once you start getting into that
then it's a totally new experience again
and once again you mentioned that sour
dough is also made making that friends
of your very you very happy yes because
remember it's not supposed to be sour
bread is supposed to be light and sweet
so this is just your raising agent yeah
but the way in which you raise this kind
of bread changes the moisture aspect it
becomes intercellular rather than
extracellular water and it's a totally
different ball game but let's not go
there no but just it's healthier it's
it's a wonderful bread and then let's
move to
something uh for lunch so you have a
salad here
Martin and uh it contains the leafy
green things now the leafy green
things whether they are in the form of a
salad or whether they are in the form of
uh a vegetable like cabbage or broccoli
or anything that's dark green that's
your calcium Source yeah when you see
the dark green you think
calcium now animal
protein because it increases the the
acid load actually removes calcium from
the bone to neutralize the acidity
because that's how your body is
wired you have this pushpull mechanism
of parathyroid hormone and
calcitonin and the one increases the
level of calcium in the bone and the
other one releases it from the bone so
as soon as your body goes into an acid
load you produce parathyroid hormone you
release the calcium from the bone
whereas leafy
greens that calcium because it comes
with an alkaline package is
automatically deposited in the bone so
if you want to have good healthy bones
you better eat grains legumes and green
things now if you take the African
diet the African diet is grains legumes
and leafy greens particularly things
like marok which is like a kind of
spinach right that they love to eat and
their calcium intake in some of the
countries like Gambia for example is
only around 400 milligrams per
day whereas in the United States it's
three four times that that quantity but
in the United States States the women
have osteoporosis and in Africa they
have none none yeah because all of that
extra that they supposedly get from
their animal products from their Dairy
is actually not taken up into the bone
but because of the acid load contributes
to release from the bone MH and you get
rid of it through the urine and you have
a little bit of gut Etc as a gift beside
so this is your uh mineral vitamin
calcium tablet yeah and also helps with
your blood sugar
absolutely and here you have a stir fry
with brown rice so then you have this is
quite a low protein diet if you wanted
to now increase the protein diet you
could add a legum yeah or you could add
a product of a legume such as Tofu for
example or you can add some nuts or some
nuts or something now some people will
say you know
Martin I've heard many people say that
tofu is so
Bland well you know what everything is
really Bland if you take meat and you
wash out all the blood so that it's just
a white pulp it's totally
tasteless so the only taste that you
will get out of it is by what you add
and exactly the same with
tofu you can make if you want to know
how to use tofu then go to the countries
that utilize it yes go and check out
recipes Thai
recipes Japanese recipes Chinese recipes
those are the countries where this is a
staple diet and learn from them how to
prepare it so that it satisfies the
pallet so a little bit of
homework a little bit of internet usage
and you can become a gourmet right so a
stir fry on rice with all of these
things added and then you will have a
pretty healthy
protein
diet and here you have a chickpeas stew
with coconut cream and bulgar wheat now
bulgar is cracked wheat it's made in a
very special way they use traditionally
these huge pots and they have a fire
underneath them and you cook the Grain
and then you spread the grain out and
you dry it like you would in the
Sun and then you put it through a mill
that just cracks
it and that's how you get bulgar so it's
already precooked that's why it cooks
very quickly yeah so that's one of the
nice things so a nice chickpea stew with
coconut cream well M there you have a
saturated fat in the mix coconut cream
let's talk a little bit about that
correct please because people will say
that's a saturated fat that's bad for
you because that's what the Mantra is
yep and saturated fat is bad for you if
it is an animal fat because animal fat
consists of steric acid but coconut
cream the fat is also saturated but it
consists of palmitic
acid then the other thing is animal fat
has zero antioxidant in it whereas
coconut cream has high levels of
antioxidant vitamin e in it so this kind
of fat paltic acid is so readily
metabolized by the human body in other
words that is a fat basically designed
for human consumption correct and any
grain will have a component of saturated
fats
palmitic acid
largely then it'll have the
polyunsaturated fats and the
monounsaturated fats and it's
interesting as you go down the line if
you take a an animal fat like butter
which is steric acid no
antioxidant when you heat that oil it
immediately forms free radicals
oxidation when you eat coconut oil
because of the high antioxidant level in
it it doesn't form the free radicals so
which one's better for you definitely
coconut oil it's not absolutely Absol
just want to mention also that some
people will have the problem probably
what we had is you at work so you don't
have time
to have your
lunch and go make it so when we changed
over from a big meal in the evening to a
the putting it in the afternoon we
continued cooking the same meal that we
would have eaten at the e in the evening
and just eat it for lunch the next day
yes that because that's one of the big
switches you have to
make big breakfast smaller lunch and if
necessary smallest yes DIN and it's
always better not to eat a big meal late
at night it's the same old argument
anabolism
catabolism the one is building up the
other one is breaking down when you go
and you sleep you want to go into a rest
phase you don't want your to force your
body to
work so if your stomach is empty when
you go to
bed then you're not forced to digest and
spend energy on that and you can get a
much better rest
phase so try not to eat a heavy meal for
supper if you have to eat something eat
something light like a fruit we must
remember nothing is a law of meats and
Persians here if you've had a hardw
working day and you feel that you need
something then then have something but
try not to eat it late at night yeah and
try not to make that a norm try not to
make that a norm all right so there you
have a wheat you have chickpea so you
have a leum by the way the chickpea is
also one of the legumes that is a
complete
protein so the wheat chickp combination
is an excellent protein so if even if
you make uh humus yeah from the chickp
and you spread it on the bread as a
spread then you have a legum wheat
combination legum grain combination
complete protein yeah so this idea that
plant proteins are inferior is a misn
correct Martin then you want to satisfy
your sweet palette and I see you've put
carab and nut clusters here occasionally
that goes off well after I see now the
carab of course is also comes from a
legum
right and uh it's largely made from the
pods but uh it is somewhat like
chocolate but but it doesn't come with
the opioids and the caffein and the
theob bromines and the other evil little
trappings that you have in that so uh
that's an excellent little end to a
meal all right Martin so we said that a
grain legum is a perfect uh example and
here you have a red lentil
spread which you can of course season
according to your palet
and a good bread a whole wheat bread
then you have a grain legum
combination and for the busy housewife
that wants to sent the kids off with a
good uh something if you put peanut
butter on that you also have a grain
legume combination correct it's not that
difficult it's not that difficult it's
not rocket science no and it just takes
some effort to start getting used to the
menu all right let's just talk about
this now what have we had here in the
diet we've had had foods that are rich
in antioxidants and phytochemicals
that's your fruits and minerals and
vitamins and everything that you require
and different foods have different
components correct so if you want to
make a snack
now for the evening and you have to
choose between something you want to
give your kids something to to eat or
something while they're doing whatever
they're
doing if you take
popcorn that is very rich in certain
minerals zinc for example is very high
in popcorn it's uh easily
digestible put a little bit of
sprinkling over it of a
seasoning and there is something to keep
your your kids occupied and keep them
happy yeah and you can snack on
something like that
whereas if you snack on the things that
you buy in the
store you're going to get uh the
saturated animal fats or you're going to
get
oxidized fats like polyunsaturates that
have been highly processed and heated so
you have a high fat refined food uh meal
that is really not good for you so yes
it's just a different mindset it that's
it I did write a book some time ago
called diet and health scientific
perspective with lots of
peer-review uh articles that are cited
in it plus a lot of our own
research and it's not in print
anymore and uh then there is the book by
Colin
Campbell and uh it's called the The
China Study which sort of corroborated
what was done before so there are all of
these studies which show that the diet
that is advocated in the scriptures is
actually the diet that is best suited
for
Humanity and The China Study was not
done from a Biblical perspective it was
just pure
science and uh the same with the book
diet and health that I wrote was from a
purely scientific perspective but the
scientific perspective happens to be in
absolute harmony with the scriptures
definitely it has to be and like we
going to repeat it if your science is
contrary to the Bible I'm sorry it's
false science correct now the
interesting thing to me was that uh many
of the
claims are absolutely the opposite of
what the world would like to hear mhm
And yet when you take it to the
laboratory
consistently The Narrative that supports
the Bible comes to the four I want to
tell you Martin that I have found the
Bible to be the most trustworthy book
definitely that exists on the planet and
it is the most denigrated suppressed
book or distorted falsely quoted book in
the entire world and and uh at every
single
level whether it be regarding the Plan
of Salvation whether it be the origin of
all things whether it be the diet best
suited whether it be the best
mental uh doctor on the planet this is
the book that supplies all of those
answers and if
people would only listen to what their
creator has told them then according to
his promise none of these
diseases would be doing to humanity what
they are doing to it now and
particularly in the time that we are
living in now yes with all of this
evidence why don't we give God a
chance because it seems to
me that very soon we will be between a
rock and a hard place and we'll have to
make a
choice
now when it comes to the issue of of
diet and health as we've
discussed and the reason why we are
doing it also in this time of disease in
the world particularly now and the
importance of a strong immune
system uh it is no guarantee mhm that
you won't get sick correct right
definitely it's and that is why it's
important that we
also learn about how to deal with the
issue once you actually do get
sick because it is so
heartbreaking to see how many hundreds
of people end up in the medical system
they go to hospital
many of these doctors are working very
hard to try and save lives but people
are dying yes and what is there that we
can
do in order to give our body the best
possible
opportunity to ward off the effects of
disease yes and if you what is there if
you do get a
disease to help the body to get through
this correct so now we've already stated
you need exercise you need fresh air you
need good water you need a healthy diet
that will supply everything that your
body and your immune system requires to
fight and W of diseases and if you do
get the disease what can you do
naturally to help your body even
further number
one is water
because water not
only uh supplies everything to your body
but also gets rid of everything that is
detrimental so water treatment whether
you use the water internally whether you
use it externally is an excellent
treatment hydrotherapy is one of the
best methods to help your body fight
disease so get into contact with people
people that know how to judiciously use
water to fight a disease and how to give
your immune system a super boost hot and
cold
compresses how do we help a body that is
overloaded with with uh toxins or
proteins that shouldn't be in the body
for example how do you rid your body of
these things charcoal it's such a simple
method uh you can take it a teaspoon or
a tablespoon of charcoal mix it in some
fruit juice or something drink it down
and it will bind toxins and take them
out of your body you can make charcoal
puses where you take uh a little bit of
boiled lint seed mix charcoal in there
spread them on a cloth and make a polter
put a piece of plastic especially over
the liver area or wherever the problem
is if you have a a wound or something a
pus like that can draw out toxins and
help your body get rid of whatever is
causing the problem there are all of
these things that we can do to help the
body overcome disease lifestyle is only
one component yeah of dealing with the
crisis and then
natural products like herb teas find out
what herb tea does what I mean there's
so much information on the internet we
cannot possibly provide the information
in a series like this no we can't and
you've made quite an extensive amount of
lectures on this so I'll put all those
links in yes but another thing that I
want to add
is just put the things that you want you
research to The Taste yes does it add up
to what the Bible says correct if it
falls in there then you can use these
remedies correct and you know simple
things like drinking water with lemon
juice in it and what temperature should
the water be when you are when you are
not feeling very well and uh what kind
of tea is detoxifying what does stinging
nettle tea
do uh what does Buu do I mean for for
things like for for example uh kidney
infections or bladder
infections I mean we we do not
necessarily in the time that we are
heading towards have access to to
medication at every single
turn but you can you can W off bladder
infections with with herbal teas and
it's amazing how how well the body
responds to these kinds of things so we
should be become little medical
missionaries in these World in this
world yeah and how people find the
natural remedies for the maladies that
are coming our way thank you very much
and just lastly the books councils on
diet and food Ministry of healing
excellent books to get a good basis as
to what is out there and what God
expects from us let's pray thank you
Heavenly Father you have given us all
the
means to have healthy
bodies and yes Lord we know that life is
not fair and some people have a worse
deal than
others but within the circumstances that
are available to us you have given us
options and I pray that you will help us
to choose the right ones in jesus' name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our Channel click here to
get notifications click on the Bell to
watch the next video click here thank
you and we'll see you again